imagina que yo soy algún tipo de banco
de inversión y por lo tanto puedo ir
allá afuera y comprar un montón de
hipotecas así que imagínate que aquí
tenemos todas las hipotecas de las
personas y cuando digo comprar una
hipoteca me refiero a pagar la deuda del
propietario de la casa en lugar de que
el dinero venga del corredor de
préstamos hipotecarios el propietario de
la casa piensa que van a pagar su deuda
el sector de servicios quienes a su vez
piensan que ellos están pagando la
cuenta también entonces si ahora yo soy
el banco de inversión compro estas
hipotecas y esencialmente en lo que me
convierto es el prestamista del
propietario de la casa y por lo tanto
ahora los pagos la hipoteca del
propietario de la casa los manejo yo el
banco de inversión así que hago esto
para un montón de propietarios que están
justo aquí sin embargo yo no quiero ser
el último titular de este cuento pues mi
papel es ser un intermediario en esta
situación y entonces lo que hago es
crear una entidad de propósito especial
y que no es otra cosa que una
corporación y adentro de ella voy a
adherir todas estas hipotecas
estás en la entidad de propósito
especial así que pego todas las
hipotecas y eso hace que la entidad de
propósito especial sea el dueño de todas
estas deudas y el banco de inversión al
menos está partiendo de que todas las
acciones en esta entidad de propósito
especial y ya con ellas el banco de
inversión empieza a vender estas
acciones es decir puede dividir esta
entidad de propósito especial en un
millón o diez millones de acciones y
vendo estas acciones a los
inversionistas y estas acciones son las
que les ponen nombre a los títulos
hipotecarios de respaldo o valores
hipotecarios de respaldo
los thr y éstas a su vez son parte de
una clase general llamada activos de
respaldo por lo que va a llegar este
dinero flotando los propietarios de la
casa al pagar sus hipotecas que ahora
esa entidad del propósito especial y así
que todo termina en que esta entidad del
propósito especial de algunas de ellas
pagarán estas hipotecas y otras no pero
el promedio de esta entidad de propósito
especial estará apta para pagar estos
dividendos